foreign
[Music]
classical career as world champion is
that correct yeah I think so how does
that feel no that's okay
um most importantly right now I think it
draws a decent result for our team and
it looks pretty good on the other boards
star last world champion in classical
chess yeah it's okay
um I scored this weekend was
um was good play wasn't great but I
might become Norwegian Champion for the
first time for for teams so that would
be nice
absolutely what do you see your chances
of becoming that right now I know you
checked out the other boards as well
yeah it's looking very good
um have you had this day this date this
game marked in your calendar is this a
special day for you uh not really uh
well in terms of the league yes but in
terms of uh World Championships they
have sort of
um sort of I was sort of immensely
finished with that a while ago
hi you play a classical game it's gonna
be as Grand Master Magnus Carl's not
to be in Magnus Carlsen is that sort of
a different feel I still have two titles
um to finish off against David Howell
has been a close friend of yours for at
least the last couple of years is that
kind of special yeah it was um
it was special
um a little bit unusual to to play them
in the serious game I didn't know really
whether you wanted to fight I always
thought for them for the match in
general a draw would be be okay
especially since I'd won the first
couple of games this weekend I thought
that would be fine so it's trying to be
solid and then I was like tiny tiny bit
better but it was never anything special
and he defended funded well and then it
was just a drop
super long games what did you expect
from from this game I wasn't so sure I
expected him to be solid maybe try and
take his chances if they were there but
to be very very solid and that was that
was correct
so what's next what's coming up for you
now in the near future
um there will be a camp with the office
bill with some young players from home
and abroad and apart from that I'll be
playing in the next championship story
events
it's sort of about uh
having a camp like you you would have a
camp before a world championship match
so is that you sort of
passing on your knowledge to the Next
Generation well I'll try but I'll try to
learn as well from from the younger
players
and in terms of online chess Champions
chess or an event is coming up in a
month will we see you playing that one
yeah I think so
great thank you
all right so David how was this
finishing off magnus's classical world
champion career with the game against
yeah obviously it's an honor to be part
of History like that but I really wanted
to put more pressure on I wanted to win
I wanted to send him out you know not on
a high so uh yeah kind of mixed feelings
but I can't complain too much what is a
good result against he is still the
world champion yes but I've still never
beaten a reigning world champion in 2010
when Anand was uh world champion I was
one move away from winning there were
like five winning moves and I got too
nervous and I only Drew and then again
only a draw today so I might have missed
my last ever shot to beat a Rainy World
Champion but uh yeah obviously a draw is
okay
your season overall in Elite City for
World War I got has been incredible how
will you sum it up uh it's been okay I
was a bit nervous because Norway's full
of these really young scary kind of uh
these really talented players and I feel
a bit old compared to them but uh it
ended okay I think I got what was it six
wins and three draws unbeaten so
um yeah it was a good season but
unfortunately my team I think we're
gonna lose today so uh
so close so close so probably second
place overall in the leader and how do
you feel about it uh proud but we won
this uh my team volaranger they won The
League last year without me so I feel
like I'm a bit of a jinx now a bit of a
bad luck but uh yeah it's been a good
season and it's been fun today was a lot
of fun
as you said finishing off in in the
DreamBox this will be known as the last
game ever for Magnus Carlsen has a world
champion is that special uh it's special
I'm secretly hoping he's gonna come back
in like 20 years and show the young
things the lesson and take the title
back but uh but yeah it's very special
and um yeah I just I just hope you
enjoyed it as much as I did
looking forward to have you back
commentating David but what's next for
in terms of playing yeah I'm not sure
Kaya uh I wanted to play the European
Championship which is on right now but
it clashed with this and I couldn't miss
the chance to play Magnus uh I want to
play the British championship in the
summer but I don't want to tell my
rivals so
um and then maybe playing for England at
the European Team Championship later
this year but um yeah I want to play
more often this has got my juices
flowing this has got me in the mood
we'll see